this is super interesting.
Our old friend, Andrew Yang, who ran for the
Democratic presidential nomination this year,
is already leading a poll for New York City
mayor, even though he's not running yet.
And there's been a movement to draft Andrew
Yang to the New York City mayor.
He's not yet a candidate.
And among Democrats, meaning within the New
York City Democratic mayoral primary, Andrew
Yang is winning.
Yang is polling 17, Eric Adams polling 16,
everybody else at 10 or below.
There's another poll from a couple of weeks
ago where it was Andrew Yang, 20, with Eric
Adams, who I believe is the council I believe
is the council president in New York City,
down at 14 percent.
So this is the twenty, twenty one election.
The New York City mayoral election is on November
2nd.
Twenty twenty one.
The primary is on June 22nd.
So we're already only six months from the
New York City mayoral primary.
And in the grand scheme of things, that's
pretty soon it'll just be five months once
Joe Biden is inaugurated.
Now, the current New York City mayor, Bill
de Blasio, is term limited from running again.
And this upcoming election is going to be
the first one in New York City using ranked
choice voting.
So there's a bunch of very interesting things
related to this.
It's very early.
The polling is basically a tie within the
margin of error in this latest poll.
And Andrew Yang hasn't even announced.
And that's exactly what makes this so interesting.
Without even being a candidate, merely with
the rumor of being a candidate this early.
Andrew Yang is already doing really well now
at the same time.
Even though Andrew Yang is not yet running,
he has signaled that he is likely to run in
a few different ways.
First of all, there are lots of people claiming
they've been told privately that Andrew Yang
plans to run for New York City mayor.
Second, there are people saying that Andrew
Yang has actually decided to run and is simply
waiting for January, maybe after Joe Biden's
inauguration to make the announcement.
But Andrew Yang has been meeting with some
important New York City figures.
Cory Johnson, who's speaker of the city council
to talk about running.
He's hired as advisors, a Bradley Tusk and
Chris Coffee, who advised Michael Bloomberg
when Michael Bloomberg ran for mayor.
So I think this is very interesting for a
number of different reasons.
Number one, Andrew Yang would bring a sort
of pragmatism to the office of mayor that
Bill de Blasio, even for as well-intentioned
as he may be, I think lacks.
And I think that would be a very interesting
aspect.
You know, one of the critiques of Andrew Yang
is that as president, Andrew Yang's approach
of sort of like the tech CEO, consultant,
technocratic approach, that it's not well
suited for the president.
It actually may be well suited for New York
City mayor in some ways, which will dig into
if indeed he he announces, number two, there's
going to be many people who if Andrew Yang
does announce that he's running for New York
City mayor who are going to say Andrew Yang
is not really progressive and there are going
to be other New Yorkers, maybe not in the
Democratic primary, but I'm thinking of Staten
Island Republicans who are going to say Yang
is a socialist because he believes in universal
basic income, which was one of his main sort
of distinguishing policy ideas during the
Democratic primary.
So you're going to have I mean, listen, it's
no different than with Biden, where the progressive
left says Biden is not very progressive and
the right says Biden is a socialist, communist,
Venezuelan, Marxist, Stalinist, whatever.
It'll be even further exacerbated because
this is all, you know, millions of people
in a very small geographical area.
So I think the contrast will be very notable.
And number three, there's an interesting identity
story here as well.
Andrew Young would be only the second Asian-American
candidate to even run for mayor.
The other was John Liu in 2013.
And then number four, because Andrew Yang
has such nationwide name recognition, it would
be very interesting to see how beneficial
that is in a New York City race.
New York City mayor is one of the least local
local races because people and companies from
all over the country, even all over the world,
have a vested interest, a financial interest
in many cases.
And who is mayor of New York City typically
for business related considerations?
What I wonder if Andrew Yang has thought of,
and he probably has, I would imagine he has
been thinking about it, is that New York City
mayor is a job where almost no matter what
you do, you are going to have a large swath
of New Yorkers furious with you about the
job that that you've done with some very rare
brief exceptions like Rudy Giuliani after
9/11.
New York City is so diverse politically, economically,
racially, in all ways.
You know, from Bronx, Queens, the Manhattan
crowd, even within Manhattan, Staten Island,
the most conservative part of New York City,
there's a large swath of the population that's
almost always furious with the New York City
mayor.
You are one of the most powerful local officials
in the country.
As New York City mayor, you run a government
larger than many states as New York City mayor.
And it comes with some horrible realities
that the mayor is always being ripped apart.
But in the end, it's not that different from
being president when half the country hates
you.
But geographically, again, the hate is in
a much smaller area and it's around all the
time.
I'm sure Andrew Yang can handle it.
Every expectation is that we'll hear from
him next month about whether or not he decides
to run and many reports that it's a foregone
conclusion that he's running.
He simply is waiting to announce.
So let me know your thoughts.
I think there were ideas of what about if
he runs for governor somewhere?
What if Andrew Yang runs for Senate somewhere?
But New York City mayor is very interesting.
And I'd be curious to hear your thoughts about
it.
And we'll have more coverage about Andrew
Yang's possible NYC mayoral run and all of
the stories from today's show on The David
Pakman Show, Instagram page, Findus, The David
Pakman Show.
All one word on Instagram and you can find
me on Instagram
at David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dotcom.
Com.